the right thing to call it is the
convergence of
sine x and tan
okay because that's really what we're
thinking about how they all come
together at the same point
at the same gradient okay but even
though this is really
kind of just a signpost along the way to
getting toward the derivative
the result we got out of this is still
kind of useful okay
so if you remember this was the limit
that we came up with
we used the squeeze law right and if i
remember right i think we had this
that's what we established okay i think
that's what we used we had
it was greater than one and it's less
than one at the same
time that's weird and so we concluded it
was equal to one okay that's what
squeeze law states
now since it's one if you remember we
could take the reciprocal of it and it
stays the same
so we use the big fancy word a corollary
of this
a conclusion that you can get from this
is that you can take the same limit
upside down and it's still the same
okay and then we repeated the result for
tan so
i could do this all the same x on tan x
as i take the limit it's one
tan x on x as i take the limit it's
equal to one okay
so this is the basic idea maybe i should
write all four of them down
so you can see them and they get
combined
in a variety of different ways okay so
let me show them to you
okay so put a nice big box
around that now the very first one they
ask us
is literally that like this one
this one so you just say it's equal to
one okay that's all you need to say
there's no proof
it's a result that we've shown and
they're not going to ask you to
reproduce the proof
complete with radiant measure and weird
squeeze lauren
kind of thing okay you can just use the
result let's have a look at the next one
it looks slightly different so how does
it affect the answer
okay well let's think about it for a
second okay i'm trying to think about
what happens to each of these graphs as
i approach
the origin right so before we were
considering
this side okay and there's
well no i totally missed sorry let's try
that again
there we go that's better there's x and
they're
tangent to each other at the origin by
the way
y equals x they're tangent to each other
in exactly the same way and sort of
for exactly the same reason that another
graph that you're familiar with
namely e to the x is tangent to a
different important line
at its y-intercept right what line is
that
going through there does anyone know
what is the gradient of e to the x
at its y-intercept figure out it's x
equals zero
right the derivative of e to the x is
just
e to the x right so when you evaluate
that
at x equals zero you get a gradient
of just one right one right through this
this line is actually x plus one
greater tension there's one that's one
that's interesting okay now if i'm
thinking about that right
how does sine 2x how does that look
different
to sine x no seriously how does it look
different
it's um i've seen people mushing with it
it's it's squashed it's compressed right
instead of getting one lot from naught
to two pi
you're going to get two lots that's what
the two tells you right
so being that it's all squashed up
instead of this
from there to there you're going to get
what you just told me two lots wow
that's really bad sorry you get the idea
okay now being that it's all squashed up
right
at this point here how is that going to
affect
the gradient that's what i'm interested
in because i know it's a tangent here
okay how would you describe the gradient
and how it's different
it should be steeper right and you can
imagine like it's kind of like a spring
uh the further i can press it excuse me
um the steeper the gradient will get at
the origin so if i put y equals x there
it's not going to be tangent okay so i
can't say
it's equal to one because it's not
they're both approaching zero but
they're not approaching at the same rate
that's what we were talking about
yesterday
so what can i do with that
the whole point of all of these is that
so long as i have the same angle
here here here here here and here
they're all gonna be equal to one okay
and i can call the angle whatever i like
you know
i can call it theta
or i could call it lambda
or i could call it
2x
2x is still an angle right it just
happens to be double the size of this
angle
okay now i don't have a 2x down there
right
but i can put one in can't i because 2
right what happens to 2 as x approaches
0. answers nothing
right so i can bring a 2 a constant in
and out of this limit okay just like i
can when i'm differentiating
or integrating okay so here's the way
i'm going to do it
i'll say now this is equal to here's my
limit
sine to x if i'm putting a 2 down the
bottom
i better put a 2 up the top right
so i haven't changed anything yet i just
multiply by 2 over 2
right but what i really want is that
side 2x and the 2x
on their own so i'll push that 2 out
it's going to be 2 times that limit
okay now at this point
i kind of have what i have here right by
the way as x approaches 0
2x also approaches 0 that's why the
limit still works
so this thing over here this limit over
here is going to be
equal to 1. okay now by the way
you might think do i really need to
write that like surely i can just write
two because i
i think we've established by now that
two times one is
two at least if you check you're working
right but believe it or not
very commonly not every single time but
usually
this one like the actual writing down of
the one
attracts a whole mark on its own
really since when was multiplied by
one's so important
now can anyone suggest to me like this
is not an arbitrary decision
why would that one be so important why
if i left off that line
why might i think okay i'm not sure if i
if this
demonstrates the same understanding as
um
it would if the one was there
any takers
yeah off the back would you say
okay so we're trying to get at the fact
that all of you all of the working
like i could go straight from here to
here i really could because i've seen
this question before
okay but i'm trying to show that i know
what's going on now therefore why do you
think it's important to have that one
bit why does the one
show that i know something is happening
see because if i leave this off right
take it back off again
put it back on take it back off what
happens to this limit
well at least in my working it simply
disappears
i just i stopped thinking about it right
and i say well it's 2 because i want it
to be equal to 2. and i could get a
calculator out and i could actually try
the values
right but by writing one let's put it
back one more time
okay by writing one i'm trying to say
i've identified this limit i know it's
equal to something
okay um it doesn't just disappear i
don't just disregard it
it's actually something important that
i've established before okay
so can you please make sure put in
another color put a big
red box around or highlight something
you need to write that one there and if
you've got
you know if i have another limit over
here
limit as x approaches zero by 10
something like that
okay guess what you multiply by one
again
because there's two limits and they're
both equal to one you're like
really i have to multiply by one twice
yes you really do
okay because i'm trying to show what's
going on yeah
you don't have this like limit as x
approaches zero
yep yep do you keep it
yeah you can i mean we're looking at
this and we're thinking oh
does it need to have a the same angle
here and here and here
you think about it two ways number one
as x approaches zero
answer for x approaching zero is
analogous to 2x
approaching zero they do do the same
thing okay
it's just that this happens to go there
faster but in some ways it doesn't
matter
because the limit is all about what
happens as i get closer and closer and
closer it doesn't matter how fast i get
there as long as i'm thinking about the
behavior
on the way okay but secondly we can
think about this
question just like the way we thought
about the original question
right which is i can compare not sine 2x
and
x but sine 2x and
2x whose gradient should match at that
point
uh according to calculus anyway okay so
no
i don't i can actually leave it as just
a regular x there but the important
thing is that those two angles match
okay all right now there's all kinds of
other combinations of that
let's skip forward to something a little
trickier let's do
sure let's do e shall we
now i call it trickier it's not that
much trickier what do i need to do to
this thing
what's my goal in order to be able to
evaluate this limit and say it's equal
to 1
what do i need
i need to get rid of that 5x at the top
and replace it with a 3x
yes so how do i go about doing that
i'm going to multiply it by
to turn a 5 into a 3 i'll multiply by
three fifths
that'll do it won't it three-fifths
times
5x that'll turn into 3x so if i
multiplied the top i should multiply the
bottom
three-fifths
okay so now at the top i'm going to get
the angle that i want
3 x and i might as well take that
constant
out the front right 3 over 5
when you divide by 3 or 5 that's the
same as multiplying by
5 over 3.
is that all right so that's five thirds
times one which is five thirds
happy with that the rest of them are
just variations on that or you may need
to
introduce some trig identities in here
for instance you can see the one with um
with cos
squared there one minus cos squared
what's that one minus cos squared
so that's that's going to be an identity
that you're going to have to introduce
right but eventually it'll boil down to
one of these kinds of situations
and you just need to tweak the
coefficients to get it in the right
shape